hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to be talking about the difference
between theatrical martial art
demonstrations traditional martial arts
demonstrations and sparring so we want
to make another comparison video because
I think it's important to understand
that a lot of times when people see
something and they think that a martial
art school looks a certain way our style
looks a certain way it's because they're
seeing just sparring or just
demonstration or just theatrical
representation right so those three are
pretty different and so a lot of times
when you see it if you see only
theatrical demonstrations from someone
you're like whoa that guy's like a god
they're so powerful they're so amazing
they can do such great stuff but you've
never seen them spar which might be very
different right and also if you only see
sparring then you think like all that's
really crude and they don't know how to
do things they don't understand
technically how stuff works and that's
because sparring's high stress and and
it's a different kind of environment
than when you see a clean form and also
traditional forms understand what
they're showing which is a clear
demonstration of a technique or a set of
ideas in the form so that you can
understand what's going on so all three
of those are different you know a
theatrical representations main idea is
to show you how cool something looks
forms idea is to show you how
technically it works and to try and
illustrate some fine points and a
sparring is actually what would happen
if two people engage so a lot of times
you know people looking at traditional
jujitsu they're all oh you know
traditional jujitsu is so much more
elegant than modern Brazilian Jujitsu
and the reason is because you really
only see demonstrations of that you
don't see a lot of sparring of that so
you're only either seeing a theatrical
representation or a demonstration of
technique like a form so so it's
important to understand the difference
between all three of those so I'm gonna
get Josh and my out here and we're gonna
show you the difference between those
three kinds of interactions with the
same two people
Josh Mya
[Applause]
[Music]
so that is a representation of
theatrical martial arts so that looks
real cool and you can see lots of cool
techniques done in there and awesome
stuff was happening and then of course
you know we added some cool camera
angles and stuff which makes it look
even better but that could be done
without the cool camera angles as well
right so that's what it looks like when
two people are trying to make a show of
something and that's what you would see
in a movie or a TV show or any kind of
demonstration where someone wants to
show really cool stuff and it's like
look at how cool our martial art can
look now that doesn't mean that that's
how the sparring is going to play out
right so so the theatrical
representation is really far from the
sparring okay let's see some of that
same stuff now as a form and remember
the forms purpose is educational so here
you should see a lot of clean stuff it
won't necessarily look real cool unless
you're into forms and then it will look
super cool but if you're not it
particularly into forms then it's just
going to look real simple and clean now
that's also going to be different than
sparring so next we're going to look at
forms and check out how that looks
[Music]
okay so that is a classic form
representation so a classic form is what
most martial arts of the traditional
style tend to show a lot of and because
they show those traditional forms so
much we think that either a they're
prescribing that that's the way an
actual conflict is gonna play out or we
think that the martial art is so elite
that if someone tried to get us with
that that we would use our super sweet
skills right and so it's hard to maybe
interpret what I just said but you know
if you're coming from a practical
martial art where you're doing a lot of
fighting and sparring and training when
you see that stuff you're like oh these
guys are silly because they think that's
the way that fighting will turn out and
it doesn't turn out that way and that's
a silly idea or if you haven't spent a
lot of time sparring and training hard
did you see that you go oh this is so
skilled that it's elevated above that
simple sparring stuff and and it'll come
out looking like this it's it's neither
one of those two the truth is it is a
really clean and simplified way to look
at the stuff that will happen in a
sparring match but the sparring match
would never look like that looks alright
so now let's check out what it looks
like with these two sparring and I would
like to say that we're gonna see the
exact second techniques but in truth
we're just gonna see what we see so
hopefully we'll see some of that stuff
if we do I'll point it out but we're
just going to see what we see so these
two are going to go at it remember these
are the same two people just trying to
show different kinds of interactions and
this is a sparring session with Josh and
Maya
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so that's an example of those
two guys sparring so you can see that
these are the same two people trained in
the same stuff representing the same
martial arts so a lot of times I think
because there is no direct compare and
contrast between the individuals we
think that like oh this guy must have
amazing superpowers or oh this guy's
just gritty or on the opposite side of
that spectrum
this guy's greedy and actually tough and
these people are kind of making stuff up
right so it's it's easy to mistake one
for the other so in this you get a real
clean compare and contrast between two
people who study in the same school
roughly the same size and what happens
when they get in those three different
kinds of engagements I'm Christopher
Hein thanks a lot for watching
[Music]